astérix et obélix mission cléopâtre le
plus gros budget du cinéma français le
film sort cet après midi c'est déjà
mission accomplie c'est le second
épisode
les aventures des deux irréductibles
gaulois claude zidi qui avait réalisé le
premier avait rassemblé tout de même 12
millions spectateurs cette fois-ci alain
chabat le metteur en scène espère encore
plus à l'humour d'uderzo et de goscinny
il ajouté celui des nuls plus jamel
debbouze bref la potion idéal voire
magique pour un triomphe marie-jo j'm'en
dominique pauthe jusqu'à nouvel ordre
aux césar
ce ne sont pas les romains qui ont
construit les pyramides
le truc point de vue là le nez de
cléopâtre d'accord il est assez joli
mais son caractère disons qu'il est
plutôt affirmé
et quand son jules césar la défi de lui
construire un palais elle est capable de
tout pour l'épater trois mois
j'oppose au top chrono ce from home et
12h30 avec premier temps de retard
heureusement grâce aux 2 x les affaires
et giteau romane vont se résoudre mais à
quel prix
43 millions d'euros budget record du
cinéma français repérages en egypte pour
l'inspiration construction du palais au
maroc en trois mois comme dans
l'histoire m des travaux à tord en 10
bits ça ressemble à l'egypte
en même temps à l'egypte qu'on fait je
pense qu allah nous a réunis nous a
assez bien expliquez vous qu'on attende
envers son sens à lui qu'on en fasse un
film un peu différent que ce les dix
commandements plus haut pas tous les
autres
il faut qu'on crève le rêve ce sont
aussi les costumes quelque 1000 mètres
de tissu un véritable défilé de mode
pour cléopâtre c'est le top du top de la
reine des reines
moi j'ai fait tard parce qu'en fait
c'est une cabane ciccio 4 fantasme
ambulant
le rêve c'est aussi la bellucci je vais
donner du volume à cette europe plus ça
nous permet de voir d'autres parties de
son corps qui était pas leur demander
snap
je peux très très gâté parce que les
robes sont magnifiques s'était pas tout
le temps facile à porter les chapeaux
lourds des robes très difficile doc
gros loi laissant les pirates l'esprit
de goscinny et d'uderzo aurait été trahi
alain chabat tenait à ce que ces gaulois
quittent leur petit village demain
oui ce sont de vieilles connaissances
nous allons souvent à la mer ensemble là
des trois personnages partent en voyage
partenaires une autre culture un autre
monde et ça obélix
ils adorent s'y obélix et astérix ont
des valeurs de l'oise évidente
la surprise vient du petit architecte
pas très fiable mais sûr de lui
la bogossité à l'état pur le regard
acariâtre le lien à quillan la bouche
charnue russel crowe alain chabat
empereur et gademann confirmé aligne les
clins d'oeil mélange les acteurs comme
les genres humoristique
résultat une potion magique très bien
dosée